we know thanks to a recent breakthrough
that it's possible to create a
believable building in planet coaster
using just a wooden plank piece but what
if we took this notion to the next level
what if we built a building using no
scenery pieces and no building pieces
whatsoever just roller coaster Trek now
that is the question of today let's get
started
[Music]
okay so you're probably wondering what
are you doing and why are you doing this
but yeah my idea for this video is to
build a building 100% out of roller
coaster track and I know that last time
I built a building using just a wooden
plank piece and the idea to build a
building out of just roller coaster
track has been in my mind for a while
but I always thought that it would be
practically impossible for a good number
of reasons well I'll go into those
reasons later but I never really dared
to do it but after the one plank
building I felt like might as well try
it and its really a bit of an
experimentation in regards to what you
can actually do with the coaster track
because obviously you don't actually
want to build a building out of just
roller coaster track you can probably
tell by the length of this video that
this turned out to be quite a struggle
and I didn't even include all of the
footage of me working on this some parts
of me just trying to figure stuff out or
copying stuff around
I didn't even record in the first place
so yeah you're probably wondering why
would you even do this and personally I
thought it's a nice experiment to at
least try and practice and do something
fun with the game just kind of flex on
you guys I guess because other than that
there's not much of a point anyway but
also building building elements out of
roller coaster track is something that
used to be really common in the roller
coaster tycoon 3 community one example
that always comes to my mind is HS
designs also known back then is hesita
escort show who builds a lot of very
industrial scenery pieces just using
roller coaster track there's also the no
custom scenery kind of community in
roller coaster q3 which used roller
coaster track to make supports for other
roller coasters and I know a guy called
Leon used to build Asian roofs using
wooden roller coaster tracks so there
are lots of fun ways that you can
experiment with roller coaster track and
I think it's something that within the
planet coaster community is kind of
underutilized
and you definitely shouldn't go ahead
and build complete buildings out of
exclusively roller coasters track like
I'm doing in this
video because as you can probably tell
it's really annoying and I'll explain in
a bit why if you can't see it already
because clearly I'm struggling to build
a pillar here but I think every now and
then there are machinery elements that
you can definitely build out of roller
coaster track and it can be a fun way to
experiment with the game and add some
very unique pieces to it so especially
in industrial or cyberpunk
or steampunk themes I think roller
coaster tracks can really help build
steel lattice structures or build very
organic elements with a lot of curves
and things like that it's definitely
something to keep your eye out for and
if you ever you know don't have much of
an idea of what you want to do and want
to experiment a bit and see what works
roller coaster track is in there in your
scenery arsenal and I can really
recommend everyone to just remember that
never forget it and always remember that
when you're running out of scenery piece
ideas the roller coasters can be used as
scenery as well just remember to disable
collisions because that's really the
entire the entire idea that makes this
viable at all also a side note I'm sorry
if my voice doesn't sound too great I
still have a cold and my nose is a bit
iffy and my throat is a bit sore so yeah
it can't be helped I'm gonna need to
play planet zoo soon so I'm gonna have
to record stuff anyway but I hope it's
not too much of a nuisance anyway I was
going to explain what makes this so
difficult and also partly what made me
confident that I can actually do this so
first of all the things that make this
possible for one we have the t-rex track
the monorail coerces track and this is
the majority of course the track that
will be featured in this building easily
as you can see here everything that I've
built so far is all using the monorail
coaster track just because this track is
a big block of one color so you can
pretty much make anything out of this
there's nothing that really sticks out
so it's super useful and it's what i'll
be making the majority of this build out
of I don't think that I would have even
tried this without the
he ranks Trek in the game what also
makes this possible is like I said the
fact that you can disable collisions in
the game settings moment you can
intersects roller coaster track in any
way that you want which is really
helpful although you can't intersect
stations into each other so that's why I
keep having to build the station to
start the coaster off with a little bit
further away from where I'm actually
building is that's a bit of a challenge
and also you can recolor track pieces in
any way that you want and you can select
any track piece and give it a different
color and usually this is not very
useful I don't think you realistically
want a single coaster to have all kinds
of different color schemes throughout
its layout but in this case it's
actually amazing and I wouldn't have
been able to do this without that
recolor ability option either because
obviously I want different elements of
the building to have different colors
and since I can't really work with
textures I needed to find other way to
make textures work so in this case for
instance the pillars have a slightly
darker beige ish color than the walls on
the background to make them stand out
and for the foundational walls I'm using
horizontal track pieces to clearly kind
of actually imitate the granites
foundation walls that you find on a lot
of classical buildings in real life but
then for the rest of the walls I'm using
these vertical track pieces which isn't
necessarily the most realistic texture
it looks more like a Victorian wooden
wall then it does an actual wall for a
classical building but I think it works
out to distinguish these different parts
of the wall from each other and the fact
that they have slight colour
differential and differentiations and
the fact that even some of the vertical
wall pieces you can see there's a
different color next to each other which
is kind of giving it a bit more of a
texture than it otherwise would have had
so the fact that you can actually change
colors is absolutely amazing
that said there are things that make
this really really difficult and one
thing that made this so difficult that I
didn't really think about beforehand is
the fact that a blueprint or a selection
or even a part of the map that you want
to delete may never contain more than
five coasters so you cannot save five or
you cannot take more than five courses
in a blueprint but you also can't move
more than five coasters at the same time
and you can't even delete more than five
coasters at the same time and because a
lot of these pieces are made out of
different roller coasters that means
that I can't move stuff around very
easily now there is a way to work around
this but this is also very difficult and
yeah it kind of makes this a bit harder
as well and that is that I make every
elements out of a single roller coaster
so each of those pillars for instance is
one roller coaster the entire wall is
one roller coaster and then the
balustrade on top of it is actually a
different roller coaster that's an RMC
hybrid coaster it fits perfectly for the
balustrade but yeah you get the idea
every element is one roller coaster
maybe a few more for just some detailing
elements but it can't be too many
because then you can't save it as a
blueprint and I needed to save all of
these pieces as a blueprint if I wanted
to this to be doable at all because I do
want to you know build a certain piece
and then be able to copy it and copy it
around and add it on all the different
parts of the building and this is really
a major challenge because if you think
about it in planet coaster the core game
mechanic I think that makes it possible
to build buildings the way that you do
in planet coaster is the fact that you
can select different pieces group them
together and move them around using the
3d gizmo and I can't do any of that with
this build because everything is to be
built out of roller coaster track and it
just can't be moved and manipulated in
the same manner so yeah that was kind of
difficult and because of that there are
also some details that are slightly off
on the pillars for instance you can see
that everything doesn't exactly line up
it's really hard to get things to line
up correctly when you're just using
roller coaster track because anytime
that you want to move anything you
cannot move individual pieces of track
you just have to build this whole
section of track to go to a different
place
then build that piece of track and
afterwards remove all of them of the
track that you use to get to that
position so that's what you see me doing
most of the time here just trying to
figure out how I can build a layout of
track to get back to a certain position
to build what I want to build and all of
this makes it very time-consuming to
build a building out of roller coaster
track in planet coaster so yeah I
definitely wouldn't recommend it this is
really just an experiment a little
cheeky test to see how it works but yeah
it's not very practical but that said if
you are just building regularly and
you're building with regular scenery and
building elements like a normal person
then you can definitely experiment a bit
with coaster track to make some elements
that would otherwise be really difficult
to make I have to say I also didn't make
it too easy on myself by trying to build
what I'm trying to build which is some
kind of classical Renaissance building
with a traditional front with the
pediments pillars architrave frieze
etcetera with the dome behind it which
we'll get to in a minute this is
definitely not the easiest thing to
build with roller coaster tracks so
maybe I could have made my own life a
bit easier but I just really wanted to
try this especially after I had the idea
to twist different rollercoaster tracks
into each other to make the pillars and
to make the pillars actually look like
they have these grooves that they do in
real life which I think works out pretty
well I think
for me at least the thing that mostly
sells this build is the fact that the
pillars look pretty decent if you don't
count the their tops and bottoms which
are a bit weird anyway I skipped ahead a
bit here to go into my experimentation
with the dome that's going to be on top
of the building and this was actually a
little bit less of a struggle I think
than most detailing because
rollercoaster tracks of course are very
good at making curves so making the dome
wasn't too annoying the the bad part
about this is yet to come and that is
trying to get different pieces to line
up to actually make a dome structure
rather than just a two-dimensional
diamond cut out but yeah so far is so
good honestly now another thing that
made this really difficult eventually is
the fact that you can't move stuff
around like you can with regular scenery
pieces which is enough of a struggle
while you're still building but it
becomes really difficult to alter your
building after you're done putting
things in place and that I think was the
major struggle and making this building
look decent and making the composition
of it look alright because as soon as
you put anything in place as soon as
anything starts looking enough like the
thing that you're going for you can't
really move it around anymore because
once this dome is completely built for
instance it'll be built out of 30
different coasters and I can't wrap the
whole thing and move it around I could
grab the different elements and move
those around but that's not the most
practical thing either so yeah you have
to more or less get things right from
the get-go or it's gonna be difficult
much later on so yeah that was a big
struggle and I should also say and this
is something that you might notice
already because even on this recording
which is 12 times sped up there are some
lag spikes because the game started
protesting against me building this and
I was not expecting this at all but the
frame rates became absolutely horrendous
at the end of this build and I'm also
not sure exactly how it works because
sometimes it would just be terrible for
a few minutes and afterwards I would
have a decent frame rate somewhere
between 20 30 FPS for a bit and then it
would become terrible again I really
don't know why why I did that but
absolutely the worst thing and something
that you might have noticed when I was
trying to save the dome as a blueprint
it's the fact that any time that I tried
saving a blueprint
the game was just freeze for a few
minutes and yeah that was really
annoying and also gave me a heart attack
every time because any time the game
freezes I just kind of feel like it
might crash any second but especially
for this build because blueprints are
the only way that I can save different
elements and move them around the fact
that making blueprints took such a long
time was a bit annoying I also didn't
save the game very often because saving
also took a few minutes anytime I tried
to do it so yeah I really wasn't
expecting this but building a lot of
roller coaster track really makes the
game run very poorly and I know it
doesn't necessarily seem like there's a
lot of roller coaster track in here but
between all of the rotating track
pillars and all of the walls being made
out of many many meters of track there
is an insane amount of rollercoasters
track in this building already so I'm
not going to blame planet coaster for
having a terrible performance when I'm
doing something that the game was never
supposed to do anyway but it's something
that made this a whole lot more
difficult and it's definitely something
that I didn't see coming when I went
into this I should also say for some of
you people who watched the the wooden
plank building and said man you put
flowers on top of this building which
you said would only contain wooden plank
that's that's cringe bro you're gonna
lose subscriber well to those people I'm
gonna have to say that today I'm not
going to put anything on top of this
building or any extra scenery elements
on any of the ballast trades or flowers
next to any of the windows this building
is going to be 100 percent roller
coaster track from top to bottom I'm not
going to cut any corners here um so yeah
I know that that was all in good fun and
I know that that was all jokes but I
take it very seriously if I say that I'm
building a building out of
roller-coaster Trek I mean it and I'm
really not going to use anything else
but roller coasters like I'll put some
foliage around this to provide a setting
for it but that's it everything you see
is roller coaster track no questions
asked
so moving on to a different part of the
building here the dome is all in place
and it's time to add a roof to this bad
boy and yeah this is a this is our MC
monorail track and as you were probably
expecting and funnily enough because of
the texture and the fact that it's this
kind of brownish gray color it looks
very much like a metal sheet roof and
quite a good one at that you could
almost use this as a regular metal sheet
roof in any park if it weren't for the
fact that it was a bit annoying to build
and might rank up your computer a bit I
think it actually works decently well
but at this point I had to save some of
the pillars move them around copy some
of the elements that I already put on
the front of the building around to the
different size of the building so the
building actually looks believably like
it's developed around all those sides
although I have to say I'm not really
decorating the back side of this
building because I'm just I'm just gonna
stick to the front this is enough but I
do want there to be you know enough
detailing that it looks like it could
plot plausibly exists and there's not
just a gaping hole at the back which
doesn't look anything like the front
does
but it's also made a bit difficult by
the fact that we don't have the grid to
help us out here because normally when
you build stuff the grid is also quite
handy to get things lined up and to get
the positions correct it's got the
distances between different parts of the
building right but in this case I
basically just have to randomly place
stuff down and try as much as I can to
match them up to other parts of the
building so yeah everything is probably
a little bit off-kilter
but that's something that I can't really
help I try to get them lined up as much
as I could by doing it by hand now this
is me finishing the dome I wanted to add
some of the the steel lattice pieces of
the Giga coaster which I think looks
really good to the dome which is just
about the best way that I could figure
out how to fill in the dome I was
considering to make it a solid dome but
for one and that would have been really
difficult to do with just roller coaster
track I would have to rotate a bunch of
stuff around and the beautiful dome
method of the 3d gizmo that people
normally use for building domes doesn't
work because you can't really easily 3d
gizmo coaster track in place because you
cannot copy a coaster which actually
also I should have probably clarified
you can't copy a coaster in the way you
do a scenery piece you can really only
blue print them and get a new copy that
way which means that you can't stay in
the same position as a coach that you
might copy around which means that the
dome technique doesn't work so yeah for
those reasons I was not too happy trying
to build a solid dome but also you know
I wanted to show off a little bit at
least that this building is made out of
roller coaster track and just have some
completely exposed roller coaster track
so this dome is actually an iron
openwork dome made out of the t-rex
track and then some Giga coaster track
to provide some extra flavor which I
think works out quite well
not to mention that openwork domes I
think actually look really cool and I
would have probably be building more of
them in Plymouth ghosts if it weren't
for the fact that
glass and domes don't work too well
together I've seen people build domes
out of glass in planet coaster but I
have an infinite amount of respect for
people who have been able to do this
because I would honestly never it's just
so hard to get glass in the right
position and get it not to overlap so
yeah I I would have been doing more of
this kind of thing if it weren't so
incredibly undoable but in this case I
felt like in an openwork dome would
actually fit the building quite well now
that is the majority of the structure of
the building in place actually at this
point I wanted to work on the windows
because obviously we don't have much
detailing yet and to make this feel like
a believable building I'm gonna need
some windows and doors and things like
that so for the window I'm using the
t-rex track of course and underneath
that frame actually I wanted to fill it
in with t-rex track as well in a
slightly bluish tint to make it seem
like this actually glass underneath that
frame which doesn't work the best
obviously a completely opaque texture
isn't the best to imitate glass with and
also the color that I chose at first
which is this kind of baby blue color I
think it's a bit too light and saturated
so that's something that I will adjust
in a minute but altogether I think it
works out reasonably well it's a
believable window I think and with this
window as for a lot of the building goes
that it looks much more believable from
a distance as soon as you get close by
it you definitely realize that
everything is made out of roller coaster
track but if you zoom out a bit and see
things from a distance I think it looks
reasonably believable enough so I'm
happy with that the only thing that I
had to adjust after the facts and I had
to take a whole underneath the building
just to see what I was doing is the fact
that I wanted to make this window a bit
more narrow and I had to fill in the the
glass in the middle a bit better because
it was still leaving empty spaces so
making sure that you know the entire
window looked clean and it was filled in
but also none of the
the glass track pieces blend out of the
frame doing that was a bit difficult and
took a lot of trial and error you know
the smaller you go in scale the more
difficult it becomes to build out of
roller coaster track hence why I would
never recommend to do this so yeah this
was quite difficult to do speaking of
which I should also mention that the
scale of this building is completely off
it's much larger than it should be and
in planet coaster things are typically
already larger than they should be so if
you put a guest next to this building
they wouldn't even come up to where the
pillars begin they would only really
come up to the top of the foundation of
the pillars so this building is
absolutely enormous probably one and a
half times bigger than it should be but
that's really just the the skill
struggle that I had trying to build a
building out of coaster track I don't
think I could have made it smaller and
still make it look believable so I'm
just going to try and scale up anything
I can so these windows are also really
large any of the detailing that I'll add
around it will be really large and the
foliage then I'll add in the end will
also be made pretty much exclusively out
of some of the biggest trees in the game
just to make this thing feel believable
I know that sounds like cheating a bit
but I think without the the bigger scale
it would have been completely undoable
that was definitely one of my other
breaking points then I had to consider
se-young copying this window around just
to make the building look a bit more
believable which I think it does a fair
job ads but then I was trying to fill it
into the dome section here and I
realized that the window was much too
large for that so I decided to set one
window apart and try to work on it a bit
make it a bit more narrow and possibly
its hauler and just change the overall
design of it because typically
especially with these kinds of
neoclassical buildings you'll have
different orders on different floors of
the building so because I have these
arched windows on the ground floor
wanted to have different type of windows
on the second floor here or the first
floor depending on where you're from and
what it all means anyway just underneath
the dome and yeah just decided to go for
some simple rectangular windows which on
their own don't work too well but they
fit very snugly between the pillars of
the domed section of the building and I
think it works very well it just in
general it makes that whole section look
better although I also have to say on
these windows especially it becomes very
clear that these are made out of roller
coaster track so especially for this
dome section you definitely want to zoom
out a bit to keep that suspense of
disbelief then it could be a real
building and not just a total warbled
mess of roller coaster track aside nomic
don't ever do watch this video while
playing a video while playing a drinking
game where you take a shot everytime I
say roller coaster you'll get screwed up
anyway
I just put in a door which is basically
a window with a different color and
that's it that's basically the building
finished and at this point I started
working on the surrounding area which
the funnily enough made a huge impact
but when you compare it to the amount of
time that it took me to build the
building itself
it took barely any time to build the
surroundings
I'm just plopping down a bunch of trees
putting some basic terraforming in this
is really not too relevant to the
building itself but it's just to provide
a sort of realistic surrounding for the
building so that you can kind of imagine
what it would look like in an actual
setting it's a bit of a strange setting
because it's somewhere in the middle of
a forest whereas typically this kind of
building would probably be somewhere in
a city but at least it makes it look a
bit more believable than being in the
middle of an empty sandbox and I think
it definitely makes a huge difference
before I put all of these trees and
ground shrubbery around it I wasn't
really too happy with the building but
now with all of the trees around it I
think it looks possible for a real
building and it looks decent enough so
I'm really happy with the way then it
came out in
anyway that'll be it for this video I'd
like to thank you guys for watching and
if you stuck with me all the way through
the end then thank you much respect I
know this has been a weird and probably
boring and strange journey through the
making of a building but I thought it
was a very interesting experiment so
yeah thanks for watching again and I
hope to see you guys in the next video
which will hopefully be a bit more
normal again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]